[Music]
thank you
to kick things off we're starting with
the state of the SNP I'm here now with
the spectators chairman Andrew Neal
who's been following the story closely
brilliant thank you Andrew for joining
us on spectator TV now in the sort of
past month or so since Nicholas sturgeon
resigned we've had for the SMP we've had
arrests resignations arguments over
membership levels a fractious leadership
election and in all your time looking at
politics have you ever seen the
implosion of a political party like this
uh I would say no I've never seen
something unravel as quickly as this a
lot of a party uh unraveling I mean of
course Liz truss's government unraveled
pretty quickly and uh I saw one comment
commentators say that in the scale of
disasters it's somewhere between the
Hindenburg and Liz truss and I think
that probably does put it in the right
context I mean
we would never have thought this even
two months ago we would never have
thought that Nicola sturgeon's departure
would lead to the unraveling of the
position of the SMP in Scotland uh and
indeed the unraveling of the
independence courts in Scotland as well
it is a remarkable change I mean only
Shakespeare could cover you know what a
falling off there was and we haven't yet
had the police report we haven't yet the
police are still uh in the middle or
coming towards the end of their
inquiries they've been as you say a
number of arrests I see speculation in
the Scottish media that even Nicholas
sturgeon might be arrested and taken in
for questioning I mean that is just
incredible so it's a story that is no by
no means over uh yet it's probably going
to get worse before it gets better uh we
still don't know what this happened to
the 600 000 pounds they read I see
there's now a rather expensive camper
van in the equation as well I mean only
in British politics got a camper van be
a credible piece of evidence so let's
see where it unravels however unravels
cannot be to the benefit of the SMP I
mean what do you think the Scottish
public make of this I mean they must be
just looking on with complete bafflement
that this sort of domineering party that
sort of dominated Scottish politics for
years is now is now in complete Anarchy
well only a few months ago Nicholas
dungeon could walk on water no she uh
even stepping over a puddle is dangerous
for her she uh she isn't waving she's
drowning and uh I the Scottish public
um are amazed at what's happened I don't
think the wholly understand it uh I
think it has discredited the SNP in the
eyes of the voters uh a party that
hitherto has dominated Scottish politics
and will in his own way I suspect still
remain the largest party but it's not
Invincible anymore it is not the voice
of Scotland anymore the way it has liked
to portray itself and I suppose the best
the context to see this is what is
happening is
the inevitable denomal of what happens
in one party States
that you've had the SMP Riding High on
the hog for a long long time now almost
for a generation uh unchallenged by any
of the other political parties in
Scotland with a rather tame media uh
which in many areas have been
cheerleaders for it with a bubble in
Hollywood and in Edinburgh where they
only there's no one there to criticize
her or the SNP indeed of anything they
want to cheer her to go further on a
party that's gotten Hawk to the radical
Greens in Scotland as well and I suppose
in some way and also you just can't
question it we saw that video of
Nicholas dungeon who got quite Surety
when anyone dared to suggest that the
finances of the SMP were anything but
Rosie and pristine and so I think all
that comes from being in power for too
long being unchallenged for too long by
not having an aggressive and robust
enough media for too long as well
although it was in the end bound to come
to an end in some sticky way I certainly
never foresaw that it would come to an
end in a tragedy of Shakespearean
proportions certainly spectacular
um where does this leave Hamza Yusuf now
I mean he's tried to relaunch his party
twice now it's obviously been
overshadowed by other events do you do
you think he even has the capability to
sort of lead the party through this
well when this week he made his big kind
of state of the union or what he would
like it to be instead of the breakup of
the Union uh Speech uh about how he was
going to run things in the weeks months
uh years ahead
almost no one took any notice it was
overshadowed by all the other events
we've been talking about and I think
that's part of his problem uh the other
events overshadow what he's trying to do
and no one's much interested in what
he's trying to do as a result and indeed
most dangerous
for all politicians is not when they're
being criticized politicians are always
criticized even for a time they can be
ignored you can survive that too things
can swing back in your favor but as I
look at the coverage of them uh across
the Spectrum he's become an object of
derision
that's very dangerous for politicians
when you're deriding treated as a joke
character not taken seriously that I
don't know how you recover for that and
I I would say they're all supporters of
the union and those who want to see
Scotland and England remain in the union
that is the United Kingdom I suspect
there ought to be crossing the figures
that the current first Minister remains
first Minister for the foreseeable
future uh because I think it's
impossible for him to deliver on the
breakup of the United Kingdom if
Nicholas sturgeon couldn't do it I see
no way that he is going to be able to do
it either so at the moment he is
probably the best guarantor of the
continued Union between Scotland and and
England at the moment and I think if
Miss Forbes his main rival was to take
over she'd be a more formidable figure
and I see a lot of commentary of people
saying he may not I'll be around for
long you know they'll do badly now
they'll lose seats to labor in the
general election they'll lose even more
seats than the next holy red election he
won't be there for long he'll be
replaced I think if you believe in the
union you want to keep your fingers
crossed that doesn't uh happen but it's
a it's a grim time for the SNP it's a
grim time for those who want to break up
the United Kingdom as a groom time for
the independence uh movement uh at at
the moment and I would say that
the union seems to me
to be as safe as it has been since
Scotland voted 55-45 to remain in the
Union in that referendum way back in
2014. would you go as far to say even
that um Independence has an issue has
been buried for a generation even or do
you think that's pushing it too much
well the problem is in Scotland we don't
know what a generation is
we were told that uh that the last
referendum had settled the matter indeed
Nicholas sturgeon implied that it had
settled the matter for a generation it
turns out that of course a generation in
Scotland maybe only five years or 10
years
and of course given male longevity in
the west of Scotland which is among the
lowest in the Western World maybe that
is the correct generation uh the correct
definition of generation in Scotland uh
gone for a generation we live in a world
where things can change very quickly
but it isn't just the crisis that
currently faces the SMP which then
becomes a crisis for the independent
movement because the SNP is the Vanguard
is the vehicle by which Independence was
meant to happen all the questions that
were raised in the 2014 referendum
particularly the economic questions uh
about what currency would be used would
there be a border between Beric and
Carlisle how easy would it be for an
independent Scotland to rejoin the EU
how would you finance the budget deficit
on Independence which currently is
financed by the rest of the Union
how could you borrow in a new currency
all these questions which were important
in 2014 they're even more important now
and not one of these questions has been
convincingly answered so whoever is
running the SMP even if they were
managed to get the show back on the road
after this car crash of a period they've
still got these questions to answer and
they've not come close in any way to
doing so so I think John Libya
generation out is not uh it's certainly
gone as a prospect Independence for the
foreseeable future and it may be now
that the SMP implosion has kind of left
a bit of a vacuum at the center of
Scottish politics do you get the sense
that labor are the ones who can really
benefit out of this or are they not also
it's not proposition will be the ones
that will benefit from this by how much
we don't know uh the Tories can benefit
from them because they're the party of
government in Westminster and there will
be a anti-government votes not just in
Scotland but throughout the United
Kingdom that is just a price you pay if
you've been in power for the
number of years the Tories have been in
power since 2010
so labor is the party that will benefit
uh and that will help Kia starma in his
efforts to form the next government
uk-wide how many seats he will get well
no no Prospect of going back to the days
when the Scottish labor party had over
40 seats in Scotland and helped to form
governments in uh in Westminster I would
be surprised if they even got more than
20 seats but they could get 15. they
could pick up it's just why I said
earlier the SNP for all its travails and
all the Messes in in my view is still
likely to remain the biggest party in
Scotland for some time to come yet it's
just people have got used to voting that
way but it pays a price for that
increasingly it's become the party of
central Scotland uh of the central belt
between Glasgow and Edinburgh and less
and less the party where it started
which is the more rural areas in the
northeast of Scotland the prosperous
north east of Scotland but it's worried
about Labor and it's coming out with
policies designed to appeal to that
former labor vote in the west of
Scotland in particular it will pay a
price for that labor will pick up a
number of these seats and the greater uh
Glasgow region and even 15 would be a
big help to kill stamina I think at the
moment he's got one 15 last time my
Loops would be 15 times the seats he's
got he's got now so I think it is going
to go to some extent Labor's way
brilliant thank you very much Andrew
[Music]